les protocoles de réouverture au coeur
de cette réunion entre emmanuel macron
et certains de ses ministres notamment
le ministre du travail de l'économie du
tourisme de la santé ou encore gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
objectif établir le calendrier les
protocoles sanitaires pour la
réouverture des principaux lieux
accueillant du public pendant cette
réunion emmanuel macron annoncé que la
réouverture se fera de manière
progressive en respectant un protocole
assez stricte et dès la première phase
la culture sera là la première phase
durera entre deux et trois semaines et
cela fonctionne bien nous passerons à la
deuxième phase voilà ce qu'a annoncé le
chef de l'état aux objectifs du
gouvernement donner de la cohérence à
l'ensemble de ce programme le
gouvernement soit bien respectée à cette
promesse et ce calendrier à savoir une
ouverture à partir de mi-mai c'est ce
qu'avait annoncé le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron lorsqu'il avait annoncé
ce troisième au confinement pour cela le
gouvernement table bien sûr sur cette
vaccination en l'accélérant la
vaccination qui a déjà commencé en
france jean castex le premier ministre a
annoncé qu'à partir de ce week end les
policiers et les enseignants de plus de
55 ans seront concernés par cette
vaccination
au total ce sont plus de 430 milles
personnels qui seront concernés une
réunion qui intervient alors que la
france a dépassé le cap fatidique des
100 mille morts le chef de l'état
annonçait que personne ne sera oublié je
vous promettre je vous propose pardon
d'écouté emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état depuis le début de la pandémie
cent mille françaises et français ont
succombé au virus
nous avons tous une pensée pour leurs
familles leurs proches pour les enfants
qui ont perdu un parent ou un grand
parent les fratries endeuillé les
amitiés faucher et si toute notre
énergie est aujourd'hui tournée vers la
sortie de cette épreuve
nous n'oublierons qu'un visage aucun nom
plus de cent mille morts donc en france
la france rejoint ses voisins
britanniques et italiens qui compte 127
milles morts et 115 mille morts
gabrielat talent le porte parole du
gouvernement avait même proposé en
conseil des ministres qu'un hommage
national soit organisée est rendu à ces
avis
si certaines familles sont plutôt pour
d'autres son encontre notamment à
certaines associations qui demandent à
l'heure actuelle que le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron reconnaisse sa
responsabilité face à ces nombreux décès